you really want to be educated to be
somebody who cannot be replaced by a
computer and I guarantee you that he
will never be able to replace the most
important part of us which is the
creativity
are you sure about that
today we talk about the boynage
manuscript the Zodiac Cipher specialized
non-human languages the Dora Bella
Cipher ciphers in general and how to go
about decrypting them great contract is
a professor of artificial intelligence
investigating natural language
processing in a way that it relates to
language reconstruction he's employed
these machine learning techniques to
attempt what can be considered the most
objective decipherment of the voynage
manuscript which is a considerably rare
Illustrated codex handwritten in an
otherwise unknown writing system it's
evaded any attempt to decode it since
the Italian Renaissance the voynage
manuscript is written on an expensive
Vellum and it's just one of the several
puzzles that Professor contract has
tackled another example being the Dora
Bella Cipher Greg kondrak is also known
for proving chomsky's statement wrong
the statement that English orthography
is close to Optimum my name is Kurt J
mungle I have a background in
mathematical physics this podcast is
called theories of everything is
dedicated to the exploration of theories
of everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but as well as exploring the
world Consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of nature each sponsor
as well as the patrons improves the
quality of the videos drastically it
improves the depth it improves the
frequency and it goes toward paying the
staff for instance someone who's editing
this full time right now and then we
have an operations manager in that vein
I want to thank today's sponsor
brilliant if you're familiar with tow
you're familiar with Brilliance but for
those who don't know Brilliance is a
place where you go to learn math science
and engineering through these bite-sized
Interactive Learning experiences for
example and I keep saying this I would
like to do a podcast on information
Theory particularly Chiara marleto which
is David Deutsch's student has a theory
of everything that she puts forward
called Constructor Theory which is
heavily contingent on information Theory
so I took their course on random
variable distributions and knowledge and
uncertainty in order to learn a bit more
about entropy now there's this formula
for entropy essentially hammered into
you as an undergraduate which seems to
have fallen from the sky however when
you take Brilliance course it was the
first time that I could see that it's an
extremely clear and intuitive form
formula that is to say that it would be
unnatural to Define it in any other
manner visit brilliant.org toe that is
t-o-e to get 20 off the annual
subscription and I recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons I think
you'll be greatly surprised that the
ease at which you can now comprehend
subjects you previously had a difficult
time grocking at some point I'll also go
through the courses and give a
recommendation in order if you'd like to
support the theories of everything
podcast and help assist that is the
improved video quality the depth the
frequency of the podcast and paying the
staff then do consider going to
patreon.com
kurtjimungle the link is on screen as
well as in the description there's a
custom amount as well as already
delineated tiers either way your
viewership is thank you enough enjoy
this conversation with Greg kondrak
Professor what is the voynish manuscript
and why is it important
about a transcript is a medieval
manuscript written in some code that is
was actually confirmed to be
actually genuine manuscript from the
15th century
it is it has illustrations it has text
the script or the alphabet is unique for
the manuscript has not been deciphered
um
yet
why hasn't it been deciphered
uh that's uh not we don't know why it
hasn't been deciphered some people say
it's because there's nothing to decipher
and it's it's just some kind of a joke
or other people say that the encoding
system is very complicated
I mean other people have other theories
about it why do people say it's a joke
and what do you make of that
yeah
well I I personally I don't think uh as
I said that this is a testable
scientific hypothesis
you can you can guess that it's a joke
but it's very hard to prove something
like that
obviously it cost a lot of money to
produce this kind of manuscript in the
Middle Ages so
that's uh one reason that I don't think
it was a joke
um well but also it it's um there's some
words showing that there are some
statistical properties that indicates
there is actually a language that is
being in code
I've seen several documentaries on the
Voynich manuscript several so not just
one or two there's a variety of them and
then there's also a whole subreddit so a
whole Reddit group dedicated to solving
this why is this so difficult compared
to other ciphers in the past like what
is it about this
well the difficulty here is that the
first difficult is that we don't know
what language it is
very often we have ciphers we have
messages but we know what the message is
for example the German Enigma machine
was a very hard Cipher but we knew that
it was German being encoded which made
it quite easier
and the second thing is that we don't
know the script or the alphabet
if that alphabet was used for something
else we would know how to speak it how
to pronounce these words
and third problem is that this is just a
unique document there's no other
document
that is it is written in this way
so it's all self-contained and we don't
even know we're not exactly sure where
it was even produced
it's strange that there's no other
document that's like that firstly that
the script is different like you
mentioned that we don't know how to
pronounce the words though even in the
Enigma code it's not as if the words
were meant to be pronounced and then
understood like that you could have
translated it to zeros and ones and it
still would have been difficult it still
would have been the same problem so why
does the fact that we don't understand
how to pronounce the alphabet make a
difference why can't we just say look
this letter appears let's call that
letter 28 let's call that other letter
50. well yeah well so we have letters
but we have words words are made of
letters that's the truth in every
language human language that you have
words that are made of
phonings they're usually every phone has
its own letter
and then there are certain
patterns regularities for example there
are certain words that can be pronounced
and other words that cannot be
pronounced and that varies from language
to language
so so the moment you you know what
language we're speaking we know you
really know the Lexicon of that language
typically a few thousand words
and they have different frequencies
so that makes it a lot easier to
decipher anything even if you just
replace every word with a number
that will still give you some
information about the frequency of the
words as long as you do something to
compare it to
I know there are different kinds of
ciphers and I believe the simplest is
called the substitution Cipher that's
like when you're a kid and you just
replace the letter A with c and so on
what other kinds of ciphers are there
yeah so the principally there are
substitution ciphers which is replacing
a symbols and transposition ciphers
which is mixing them up changing their
sequence
and every Cipher is a combination of
those two methods
now we don't know what is varnish we
don't know if it's just a simple
substitution or is it a substitution
combined with transposition
the paper that we wrote assumed that the
transposition was involved
and we try to come up with a general
method of breaking this kind of ciphers
that combine substitutions in just
positions
I completely glossed over the history
actually I not that I glossed over I had
forgotten to even ask you to give the
audience an indication as to where was
this document found why does it matter
why is it that Scholars even care about
it I'm sure there's plenty about the
past that we don't know about so why is
it that many scholars and not only
Scholars groups of people teams of
people on Reddit are pouring over trying
to figure out what the heck is this
saying where was it from can you give a
bit of the history of it please
sure so sorry was found basically by the
person whose name was Vonage that's what
it's called the Voynich it was a kind of
a collector
uh in the beginning of the 20th century
and since then the the manuscript has
been tracked back to 17th century to the
Court of uh Roman Emperor and that's
where it kind of ends that's where the
Trail Ends
uh but as uh not long ago there was a
chemical analysis done on the manuscript
so we're certain that it was actually
written in the 15th century
so there is no doubt about that anymore
now you also asked the other question
which is why are people so fascinated
with it
I think the main reason is that we are
fascinated by puzzles if we see
something that seems to be a message we
want to know what that message is we
want to decipher it
and Voyage is like a Mount Everest of
all
uh overloading
cryptographic puzzles
it was actually
studied by many years by people that
were working for the U.S government
and that they were professional Breakers
code Breakers that that broke cause
during the second World War
in the case of the Enigma code we at
least we could presume that it has
something to do with government secrets
and War whereas with this do we have any
indication as to what the subject matter
is
well we have the illustrations that's
what makes it really interesting is and
we have plants people medicines
all kinds of strange illustrations that
seem to be related to the text
so so this is not just a text like some
kind of ancient inscription but it is
actually a codex which is like a
compedium of some kind of knowledge
which was quite common in Middle Ages
and is it quite common among a
particular group that speaks a
particular language and thus we could
figure out okay with this amount of
probability it's from this culture or
this group of people
yeah so many of those codex codices are
in Latin which was the language
of literature and Science in Middle Ages
and you can actually find such such
books very similar similar looking for
Middle Ages that are written in Latin
the best guess is about the provenance
of the manuscripts uh point at Northern
Italy
were of course Latin was the language of
literature as well at that time
is it controversial that it's in the
15th century and in Northern Italy
almost everything that you can say about
foreign so
this is what I consider a reasonable
guest but
and pretty much everybody has a
different opinion where this uh this
manuscript comes from and what language
it represents
I I don't have any it is not my research
that points to the Northern Italy
I only looked at this manuscript from
the point of view of computation
decipherment
speaking of your research now would be a
great time to tell the audience what is
it that you study and then how the heck
did you become interested in the
voendage manuscript other than a general
curiosity for solving puzzles
yeah so I I'm a computational linguist
I'd say so I I work at the computer
science department at the University of
Alberta in Canada
and I work on language in general making
computers understand human language
making a rewriting programs that can
process human language and do the work
for us because there's so much text
that is available that nobody can
actually read that all of that all of it
about the the decipherment
the person that made this really
interesting for me was Professor Kevin
knight from University of Southern
California
and he worked on various interesting
projects and I saw his presentation of
wineish manuscript
about 10 years ago I I say
and it it was related to what I was
doing
what Kevin Dr Knight said basically is
that everything we do with language is a
kind of decipherment
because language
we is typically written that's what we
work with a written language even if
it's spoken we work we work with some
form of it that is a transcription
and whenever you have a sequence of
symbols it becomes a decipherment
problem basically deciphering first what
are the phonemes behind those symbols
and secondly is the meaning behind the
symbols
with respect to the images in the
Voynich which will overlay on screen is
it strange to depict what they depict
the pictures yeah yeah like what are the
pictures of and is there something
unique about them
yes so so the generally if I tell you
that it depicts plans for example that's
not strange because that's what the
medieval codices do but if you look
closely at those plants if you're an
expert in Plants I am not but
experts on Plants look at them and say
well these don't really look like real
plants these are look like made up
plants
and then there are pictures of people
that some kind of many naked bodies
taking baths
in some kind of green water
you know in general pictures of people
are not strange but those particular
pictures are really strange
and they are unlike anything else that
we know from middle age
they're strange because they're naked or
they're strange because they're depicted
alongside plants like what is it
specifically that's unique
The Exchange because it's not clear what
they are depicting are they depicting
people taking bath that I don't think
was very common in Middle Ages
or why are why are those figures for
example all women and why they are naked
right in 15th century that that was not
a normal thing to put in a book
um there are also other things like
zodiac signs or or pictures of plan of
of planets
that you would expect to be
to be quite normal because we even know
those the what those Zodiacs are
but it's it's difficult to connect the
words that describes those pictures to
the actual pictures
in one of the documentaries that I was
watching about this they said that a
remarkable element is that there are
extremely few errors in a writing of
this size they would expect that there
are some errors and then maybe you
smudge it out or however they correct
errors and there's some way of detecting
the frequency of the errors in a
document and most documents have let's
say error percentage two two percents
they make an error every two out of 100
words whereas this it's much lower like
half of that or even half of half of
that first thing I want to know is that
even true and then secondly like why why
do you think that's the case what could
that mean
yeah so first of all I did not work with
the actual text I worked with the
transcription that somebody made
but it is from what I know it is true
that there is very few Corrections
my personal opinion that it may indicate
that whoever was writing this copying it
did not understand what they were
writing you usually make Corrections if
you write something and you see oh it's
that's not what it should be right but
if you write something in a language
that you're totally unfamiliar with you
won't be able to notice that that's
interesting in that case that would
imply that there's another copy no that
means that I I there were people that
maybe were copying the text
into the manuscript because that was a
you would expect there was some draft
that we're copying from because the
manuscript itself was very expensive uh
to write down and we also know that
there are different kind of hands so it
looks like they were more than a one
person doing the copying that's
interesting then that means that it's
extra difficult to decipher it because
there are errors we don't know this but
that would mean that there's more than
the average amount of Errors what's the
difference between inciphering so
creating a cipher out of something and
then encryption
yeah I'm not sure if there is a
difference you know if you really try to
find the difference you could say that
encryption is
like you do encryption of a text but you
don't really know how it is done you
know you apply some encryption program
whereas in ciphering implies that you go
like letter by letter look up the key
and then Cipher each each letter
separately
but in general I think it's it's pretty
much the same thing
what were the different methods used to
decipher the Voynich manuscript not just
by you but by others what techniques do
they employ
well that's a kind of difficult to say
because none of those methods actually
worked and then deciphering has not been
achieved in spite of many claims
to the country so
the there isn't really any algorithm
involved it's it's mostly based on
people's intuition and and theories
but but even then uh if even if there
was some method to it it has not
produced a readable transcription
what are some of your attempts to
decipher can you go through the
successes and failures
yes so so uh in our project our
assumption was that the first thing to
basically to start with is to find out
what language this is written in if we
don't know what the language it is
written and then there's no way to
decipher it
so we devised some methods of detecting
identifying the language of the cipher
even without deciphering it
and we use the sample a large sample of
about 400 languages
and out of those far-handed languages we
assign like a number as score to each
language
in terms of the probability that this
language is the language of the
manuscript
and what was interesting that we found
was that the language that was the the
highest scoring language or out of those
400 was Hebrew
how much higher was it than the second
and third place
was a clear difference I would say a
significant difference between the
second one in the list
so that was quite striking
and were you able to get any other
historical documents that are written in
Hebrew that have a similar art style and
are of similar length just to see well
is this common is this a common practice
to the people who write in Hebrew or is
this aberrant is this extremely unique
so the Hebrew manuscripts exist and they
were written throughout Middle Ages in
Hebrew
by by the Jewish Scholars
and I'm not the only person that that uh
that hypothesized that this this was
actually coming from from the Jewish
scholar community
uh now nobody used this kind of
particular script
but this script
does have some some similarities to
Hebrew script for example
I actually don't speak hero uh or or I
don't know much about it but I know that
the Hebrew script does not include
letters sorry include vowels which makes
the words shorter
and this is what we observe in vanished
is that the words are quite short
and then the number uh the number of uh
different symbols suggest that it is
something like a substitution Cipher
because the number of symbol is similar
to the number of phonemes in a typical
language
okay so now that you have at least
potentially identified the language
what's the next step
yeah a very good point so the next point
the next step is obviously try to match
every symbol to a different letter of
the say Hebrew
alphabet
and that usually is easy the breaking
simple substitution Cipher's disease but
it doesn't work in this case it does not
produce any sensible decipherment
so we came up with this hypothesis that
the letters within words are actually
transposed to make it more difficult
to decipher
and when you kind of move the letters
around it becomes very difficult to
decipher it so we came up with a method
that could handle this kind of
transposition
within words and we tested it on other
languages and it worked very well
however when we apply this to uh the
varnish manuscript it still does not
produce any kind of a readable
decipherment
when you're testing it with other
languages are you testing it with
ensipherments that you contrive or are
you testing it with ciphers that already
exist from those other languages
no we tested it on a mass scale with uh
with synthetic Cipher so computer
generated ciphers
but these are generated from the actual
text in those languages
you mentioned that there's two kinds of
ciphers at least so far so there's
substitution and then transposed or
transposition what else is there so Pig
Latin where you just you add some words
is that considered transposition
no I think Pig Landing is like a game
what I'm saying is that it seems like
there are other methods that exist even
if they're silly so there's
transposition there's substitution is
that primarily it or is there a seldom
third
well I would say even big Latin you can
express it probably as some kind of
substitution uh or and transposition
right so so these serious ciphers like
in Enigma is is basically again a
combination of substitution and intense
position uh actually Enigma is just pure
substitution really there's no
transposition there except that of
course the spaces between words are
removed
well that's disappointing you're like
okay great I've made a Headway I found
out that it's Hebrew at least you're
somewhat confident it's Hebrew then you
say well okay let me devise some way of
deciphering any substitution plus
transposition combination it works on
other ciphers great let me apply it here
doesn't work so now what are you
thinking and what's next
well first of all I'm not confident that
it is actually Hebrew all I can say is
that out of those 400 languages that we
had samples of this is the one that got
the highest score
so if I had to pick one of those 400
then I would pick here but the language
may actually not not be in that 400
sample it may be a there's thousands of
languages in the world
and in addition it may not actually be
actually any human language some people
hypothesize that it's a made-up language
like Esperanto can this thing
so of course we were excited to see some
kind of clear preference for one of the
languages
but
and and we applied a kind of a
scientific
methodology to it so we reported those
results and they are replicable if
somebody else applies this to that
sample they will find exactly the same
thing but that doesn't mean that this
language is actually Hebrew
so uh yeah
if if I was really convinced that this
was Hebrew I think the next thing I
would have to do is to actually learn
Hebrew because
that would be the only way to decipher
that complicated uh manuscript followers
but of course uh I have a lot of other
projects to do so I'm not going to study
Hebrew for that purpose but there are
many people that know Hebrew and uh
and I'm sure if if this was really
Hebrew they would be able to to decipher
it
and themselves so if someone watching
speaks Hebrew and is a computer
scientist and they also want to help
what should they do contact you or is
there some program that they run
because I've been contacted by so many
people I'm just gonna put on screen
please contact crondrak here's his email
address and his private phone number
yeah I uh some of those people
uh were actually experts in Hebrew and
in computers and in ciphers
and even they they could not make any
progression so then why do you think
that if you were to learn Hebrew would
help
no I said that if I really was 100 sure
that it's Hebrew then that would
definitely help to know Hebrew right my
work is from a point of view of a
computer scientist not from a point of
view of a linguist or or a cryptographer
so it's not as simple as saying identify
the language then suggest the different
rules so that is the substitution slash
transposition combination and once you
have that feed a text any text that is
in that language and is some unknown
substitution slash transposition
combination and outputs it tells you yes
or no it's not as simple as that
so you know as I said the the main value
of vines manuscript is that it forces
you to come up with new methods that
later may turn out to be useful for
other things
what we came up with is is a methodology
for doing this and it we proved it in
our paper
that it works
maybe at kind of 95
accuracy if you take a language whatever
language speak any language
provided Us in that 400 sample
substitute letters for other symbols
scramble them
give it to our program it will decipher
it with 95 percent like
so that so that is proven and that is a
replicable thing that
was published in the paper
but
but that is made on the assumption that
that it is actually a actual human
language
included in that set 400 languages that
is being used for that purpose
the fact that it doesn't work with
Voynich suggests that Vonage is not
written in Hebrew or any of those 400
languages
so you ended up testing it on all 400
no we tested it on a smaller subset I
think with six languages
um is it just computationally too
difficult to do all of them like it
takes up too much time can you not just
tell the computer to run with it
the problem is that you need to build
What's called the language model for
each language
and for that you need a lot of texts and
the European languages
usually all of them have a lot of text
like people write newspapers in them but
if you pick languages that are very
small or very exotic and it's very
difficult to find any electronic text
written in those languages
so so then it's very difficult to
to derive a language model from those
texts because they are too small
that was the reason
yeah it's quite the conundrum
at least you were able to develop some
new techniques that can be applied to
other problems have you made any other
progress other than what you've just
indicated
so I mentioned that we worked on another
undeciphered text how about we just
transition to that and I'll come back
and forth to the Voynich at different
points why don't you tell us about the
Dora Bella cipherite
you know for me like I know there are
people that just spend their all their
lives on Vonage right they're like
obsessed with Voynich but for me it was
just one projects of many
so after running chapter we decided that
we've done everything we could with it
we left it to other people to to puzzle
over and there was another uh Cipher
that caught my attention which is called
the durabella cipher
and this was written in 20th century we
know who wrote it
it was an English composer
who wrote a postcard to his friend
and that first part was was the cipher
it included the cipher which is about 80
characters
in a kind of a strange script
and that that postcard survived and was
published after his death
and the the composer's names is Elgar
um and nobody has been able to decipher
that short text
so that's the durable a Cypher another
undeciphered
safer
and now our approach was that maybe you
know this is not a text any language
text
maybe this is just music because that
guy was a composer so what happens what
will happen if we try to decipher into
music
so we came up with algorithms and
implemented programs that can take
a short text like that
uh well even I mean not tax but a short
piece of music that is encoded in some
way and decipher it
uh and uh and that's what happened and
we we published a paper that
at the end produces a kind of a
reconstruction of a Melody that is our
best guess
at the decipherment of that Cipher into
music
you said A peculiar statement about the
Voynich manuscript that it may not be a
human language now do you mean to say a
language that large groups of people
speak or that is an alien language like
it's not a homo sapien
it could be a made-up language right so
you know that
actually there exists languages that
were invented like Esperanto
and many languages like hundreds of
languages have been invented this could
be one of those a language that was
never spoken by any Community but
somebody just kind of made up
a language and and it's possible anybody
can do that in learn their own language
I see so it's still it's a human
language in the sense that it's made by
a human but it's not a human language in
the sense that it's not spoken by many
people or even known about
so it's not as if the alligator made up
this language or some other extra
dimensional entity made up the language
or divinely inspired
that's right the better word is probably
natural language we say natural
languages the languages that occur
in in uh on the on the planet spoken by
some community of people I see Stephen
Bax is another professor who is no
longer with us but he studied this
manuscript and I'm curious if you can go
through what his theory is on it are and
then also your commentary on them
well actually I'm not an expert in in
history or or any other theories
you know the the
ultimate test of a theory is that it
produces a decipherment
right so
uh as far as I know no reasonable
decipherment has been produced by Dr Bax
or anybody else
so uh it's it's not a huge motivation to
study somebody's method
if that method has not actually worked
but how does one go about the process of
learning a language from a computational
perspective
so you know everybody speaks a language
that's the universal thing every human
being they have their own native
language plus the image speak other
languages
but the majority of people I I think
they just learn very well their own
native language and they learn it as
children
if you try to learn a language
after you're like something somehow like
10 years old then you'll find out that
it actually becomes a different process
it becomes more difficult and you
actually have to school you have to go
to school or study books or go on the
internet
and somebody teaches you a language this
is not how children language
so this is a big difference between the
native language and the second language
that we learn for example when I speak
different you can probably tell that
English is not my first language
my first language is Polish
so
because it's not my native language and
because I learned it as a teenager
you can tell from my accent that uh that
I'm not an native speaker right so uh so
this already tells you something about
what people call the language Instinct
the the ability of people to acquire
language
now Linguistics is is uh is a
science of
of the language which deals with various
aspects of the language and those
include things like formatics and
morphology
grammar syntax semantics pragmatics
acquisition many things what are
pragmatics briefly sorry
yeah pragmatics is probably what you are
most interested yourself is
is uh basically for example a sentiment
analysis is pragmatics right if you if
you deal with sentiment analysis you're
not really interested in finding out
what people say but what they feel about
what they say right so that's that's
what we call pragmatics it's not just
about the message it's about all the
other stuff upon it how do we feel about
the message that sounds terribly
complicated
is it no it does well it's it is
difficult but uh but uh but it's doable
and it's not the hardest part it's it is
one of the tasks that people do and and
we have programs now that are very good
at it okay so continue on where you were
please
yeah when you say that it sounds uh very
complicated is because it's hard to
Define exactly what we mean by things
like sentiment like me you mean like
what do you mean sentiment like and then
people say well are you angry are you
happy
are you sad
and then how many feelings do we have
well we have eight feelings
really eight no maybe 12 right so this
these are things that are very difficult
to Define it's much easier to deal with
things like letters or phonemes where we
know exactly how many letters or phonies
we have in the language
and it's easier to write programs that
deal with that yeah so I'll I'll give it
a try so so you can imagine it's like a
pipeline so you start with when you hear
somebody speaking you start with what
are the sounds of the language right
that's phonetics
and now once you've done that then
you've tried to figure out where one
word starts the the other ends right you
want to see you want to identify the
words because there is only a limited
number of words
and that's the what we call lexicon or
lexicos
and then you when you look at the words
you see that they are made up of sounds
or letters
but they also made us something bigger
which is called morphemes
and uh and that's the stuff of
morphology that's the study of
morphology for example if uh if I say a
word like ungrammaticality
and then you can say well there are
three parts of it the an the grammar and
the ality
and that's the morphology
so so these are considered the kind of a
low level low levels of language and as
you go up it becomes more interesting so
first of all how are words put together
into sentences
how is it that you can have sentences
that you ask somebody is that a proper
English sentence and they say yes or no
they can tell even though they have no
idea they haven't studied linguistics
every native speaker can tell you if a
sentence is grammatical or not
that's the study that Noam Chomsky did
in the 50s
can we write a program that can tell a
grammatical sentence from an
ungrammatical sentence
and on top of that on top of syntax is
semantics which is about the meaning of
words we can have perfectly Dramatical
sentences that are meaningless
and vice versa we can have meaningless
utterances that are not grammatical
and then on top of cement it is
pragmatics which has all these things
that are difficult to Define and that
appear to you very complicated this
Universal grammar of chomsky's it's true
in the sense that you can create a
program that can identify which
sentences are grammatically correct and
incorrect
actually I don't think so I think that's
what Chomsky tried to do all his life
but
it has not it has not been done as far
as I know
but at least that was the state of the
earth about 10 years ago now the the the
last few years we have seen the the
neural language models appearing which
are extremely effective
and which as you know can produce a
completely grammatical and text that
also makes sense yeah so so by extension
that means that these these uh programs
can tell the difference between a
grammatical and ungrammatical centers
because they only produce grammatical
sentence
are there other Universal Concepts in
language like Universal grammar
uh so the universal Concepts in language
are the things that are in every
language
on Earth every natural language if if
there is something that almost all
languages possess but some languages
don't then it's not Universal
there is a whole area of linguistics
that is dealing with finding things that
are Universal in human languages
and I as far as I know there is a long
list of those things have you used any
machine learning or neural language
processing in the decipherment of the
Voynich
we did use machine learning but not
neural methods no the the
reason we didn't try we didn't use the
neural methods for decipherment
I I think you have some experience
already with these neural Bots is that
they can make sense of everything so for
example Google translate if you give it
a something that doesn't make sense it
will still translate it
into something that does obviously we
don't want something like that to be
applied to voynish manuscript because we
want to really know what's really there
not how to make sense out of it
in some way right
there isn't some way of identifying what
makes sense and what doesn't in the same
way that for some sentences you can
identify if it's grammatically correct
or incorrect like that program has not
been completely explicated like you
mentioned with Chomsky but maybe there's
huge progress there is there not
progress in saying the sentence makes
sense or not
that is much harder to do there is
progress yeah every year there is
progress
but we are still far from reaching that
point
you've seen that there's chat GPT and
there's open AIS gpt3 what's your
opinion of them are you excited by them
are you surprised by them
I am excited that those tools become
available but I'm also kind of worried
that people are too enthusiastic about
them
and they for me the problem is that
they are basically what somebody called
parrots right they they're parrots that
have heard a lot of language being
spoken everything that was ever written
and they are very good at repeating
putting together those sentences and
words together
but there is no really under no real
understanding underneath
those systems cannot tell us why they
think
the these things that they say are true
they basically repeating
the words that have been written
somewhere and rearranging
to be fair most people when they're
putting out something that's creative
they're just repeating what they've seen
and they're mixing it up and they
believe it to be absolutely new and also
just so you know there is something
creative about mixing up and then
presenting it and furthermore most
people maybe even all of us we don't
know the motivations like will
confabulate some reason for why we
created so and so like that's why the
whole field of psychoanalysis came about
because we don't know why we do what we
do we make up some reason so why does it
matter that the computer doesn't know
why it does what it's doing and that
it's quote unquote
repeating while mixing let's say mixing
what's old
I don't think it matters if you're
interested in a computer producing art
like writing a song or painting a
picture
but it doesn't matter if you rely on the
computer to tell you what the truth is
right
because if you don't if somebody cannot
explain to you why they believe
something is true
then how can you trust them
these are deep questions
so yeah what I find remarkable is that
you can just even a simple program
asking it to code this in Python code
something that does this in Python code
something that does this in autohotkey
or whatever it may be and it does it or
does it 90 the way there who the heck I
didn't think that that would be possible
for quite some time there's something
truthful about that in the sense that it
works like you can actually test if the
code works so that's a test of Truth
more so than a statement are you happy
about that or you feel like even that
old technology that could have been done
five years ago or
so well the program programming is a bit
different story right because
you can actually test programs right
so if some if you ask
whether it's a human or it's a bot to
write a program you can
you provide a specification then you can
go through the testing the test
procedure and find out if that program
really does what it does right so we
don't actually have to trust
the pro the trust anything we can just
test it right but if we don't if we
don't if if we don't have time to test
it then I would be wondering whether
it's a good idea to depend on such a
program
so going back to the voyage have you
thought about if it's composed of at
least one language like maybe there are
multiple
you know uh it could be it could be a
lot of things there you know the the you
can make these uh encryption systems as
complicated as you wish
so so it's all possible there is no
there is no limit there will be no limit
where we can say well we tried
everything and now we know it doesn't
make sense so it must be some kind of a
joke or some kind of random generator
but uh what is fascinating about Voynich
is that we can use it to actually
create new things right so
we take decipher and we create a Melody
right
and and many people take advantage and
they produce decipherments that
are like their own pieces of of art like
their own books the only problem is that
everybody produces a different one so
none of them can be actually correct but
it is still a creation
so I think that is that is very good
about varnish that it exists
have you thought about Voynich from less
of a computational perspective and more
just from a human motivation one what
the heck is this about why would someone
go through such lengths to decipher this
or maybe it's not even lengths like you
mentioned it could be something trivial
we're just overlooking like what are
their theories come up in your mind just
surmising just conjecture
yeah so one of of the more interesting
theories that I've encountered actually
comes from this U.S expert
on decipherment
at in the end he said
that he thinks this is a an artificial
language somebody created an artificial
language
and wrote that the foreign that language
well if that's the case then it's it's
very difficult it would be very
difficult to decipher it because we
don't know the principles of that
language
it could be a language that is
completely unpronounceable it's just a
sequence of symbols
um yeah so I think that's that that is
one theory that that is for me the most
convincing
what else have you heard that is at
least somewhat convincing maybe this
one's at the top but is there a second
um
you know when I look anybody can look at
those illustrations they are on the web
right and if if you look for them for a
long time
sometimes I think this this somebody was
not quite
it wasn't it was a work of an expert it
was a work of somebody who actually
didn't know what they were doing and
just try to
create something like what they saw
before in other codices in other books
a little bit like a neural language
model that just looks a lot of things
yeah
she's a lot of reads a lot and then
produces something that looks like
it should make sense but it doesn't huh
that's interesting
we know that those language models can
be tricked to produce texts that just
seem to make sense about complete
nonsense right for example why it's good
to eat crushed glass right
it will give you all the all the reasons
for that why it is good to eat first
class
when it comes to the doorbell Cipher
there were some other people who came up
with decipherments I'm going to read
some right now starts Larks it's chaotic
but a cloak obscures my new letters a b
Alpha Beta that is the Greek letters
below I own the dark
and then there's others like why am I
very sad and so on I'm sure you've heard
these
yeah what do you mean yeah okay what do
you make of these
I've seen this before but it always
makes me laugh when I hear it's this for
me is complete nonsense
why why
well it is it is nonsense to imagine
that uh a distinguished uh English
composer would write something like that
to his uh love interest
if you were to decipher Voynich what
would be next for you no more ciphers or
do you have your eye on another one
you know I I think
did this happen I mean varnish has not
been decrypted but there was a very
interesting uh deciphering recently of
uh of actual Cipher which was called the
Zodiac Cypher I don't know issue right
right yeah
and that that is actually correct right
that that decide for me is not fake
it is actually a correct decipherment
so I I would probably ask that that
person about their feelings like what
how they feel
about cracking that Cipher is it like a
complete Bliss or is it like some kind
of disappointment that
and I put so much work into it and then
I find that this text is actually
kind of you know not interesting at all
it's like some kind of deranged mind
writing it
so uh yes you know there are one one
kind of tragedy is if you don't achieve
your goal and the other tragedy is you
if you do it you should go
yeah that's interesting hey let's get
philosophical here to me that means that
you have to enjoy the process more than
the state even though there's some end
States and that's supposedly driving the
process you have to fall in love with
the process because you may if you're
lucky and maybe unlucky reach that state
yeah absolutely and this is something
that I do feel about problems in
computational linguistics that
and that I love doing this stuff and uh
I just would be able to do this you know
for free
and if because it's it's such such huge
fun to do this
but the Vonage was just one of the
projects that I got interested in and uh
I learned from the project I I got some
experience from that project that I
think made me a better scientist
so that I can apply this experience to
the projects that are not that actually
do have a solution
well right now and we are very excited
to be working on semantics on lexical
semantics and
and we are proposing uh we you know we
are finding things that other scientists
find Maybe
uh controversial right
but the huge the huge advantage of of
the work that we do is that we can
actually provide proofs mathematical
proofs of of what we do
and this is this gives us the
satisfaction of of actually being
certain that we are doing something
right because we can prove it
going back to loving the road more than
where you're going I feel the same with
this podcast it's about theories of
everything and the physics sense so my
background is in mathematical physics
and a part of me I feel like I'll be
extremely disappointed if I encounter or
if we discover as people as scientists
the theory of everything there is
something that's terribly fun about
learning it and investigating so I don't
want it to be over
I don't think you have to worry about
that
personally I think
you know looking at how the universe is
constructed I'm pretty sure it has some
built-in mechanisms
so that we can never actually figure it
out completely
what gives you that intuition
well you know the the
yeah yeah you know like this when you
talk about theories of errors in you you
obviously talk to physicists so uh and
that deal with quantum mechanics and
things like that
and how there are certain principles
that we can prove that we'll never know
the truth right like we'll never know
where the particular particle is what is
the its exact location and speed and so
on
and this uh this just this is for me an
indication that these things are
constructed in such a way that we will
never be able to crack them completely
all right well that's hopeful but also
dismaying
at least it's both and not one without
the other so about the zodiac
if that's a substitution Cipher was it a
substitution and transposition or just
substitution
oh yeah it was substitution entrance
position and it was a very tricky dance
position too yeah why is that and would
your method have worked on the Zodiac
one
no the the battle would not work on
zodiac because the Assumption of our
methods was that we know where the words
are so in varnish there are spaces
between words
and we made this assumption that this is
not just to confuse but they are
actually words right
now in the Zodiac Cipher there was no
spaces between words
so
although it is possible to kind of
hypothesis where the spaces are that
method that particular method would not
work on zodiac
and the method used to crack the Zodiac
Cipher can that method or methods be
used to help with the Voynich
I actually you know I don't think so I I
think the the the key of the
decipherment in that case was just
finding the a specific pattern right
of transposition
so it was not any kind of cool new
Theory that is general and can be
applied to various things it was just
kind of a
stroke of lack there that like trial and
error
it is always a child in there when you
do actual decipherment but what I mean
is that
there is no method behind it that can be
generalized and applied to other things
how it's Ai and maybe this is a term
that you don't want to use but how has
AI aided your field so instead of saying
AI then reference the a specific model
like Gans I've changed my field because
of social supervised learning in the
form of a b and c changed my field
yeah so you cannot uh you cannot can you
avoid the word neural nowadays when you
talk about language
understanding
uh it's it's a it's a powerful uh new
tool and everybody is very very excited
about it including myself
so it of course it changed everything
because
what the story of language processing is
that it started from a kind of a
symbolic processing
and then moved into the machine learning
stage and then evolved into the the
neural methods which we use nowadays so
what is exciting about it is that every
few years you have a new Revolution and
a new methods and and we make constant
progress to the point that some people
think
that the problem of language has been
solved but it's not the case
sorry that the problem of language has
been solved the program of language
understanding has been solved that that
we can basically now have programs that
will do every language related task that
we want
and it's not true who thinks that that's
that that problem has been solved
well you know when I read these uh
articles about the the neural Bots that
can you know write
uh newspaper articles or or
compose Symphonies or something that
sometimes you get an impression that
well we're done right we can just leave
it all to the computers
and they will they will do everything
for us
but what I tell my students is that you
really want to become to be educated to
be somebody who cannot be replaced by a
computer
and I guarantee you that they will never
be able to replace the most important
part of us which is the creativity
are you sure about that what is it about
human creativity that a machine can't
replicate by the way I'm not being
skeptical I just don't know I'm curious
what your thoughts are because since
you're in this field
well that's exactly what you said
machine cannot replicate creativity and
replication are are opposite things
creativity is doing something that has
not been done before
of course you can say well it's just
kind of building on what was before but
it's not replicating it's not parroting
it's creating something new based on a
deeper understanding of things
well there's this old joke of if you
want to create an apple pie from scratch
you have to first create the universe
it's like well did you get it from the
farm no I bought it from this okay but
even if you had it from the farm that
you grow the dirt did you well yes okay
but did you make the cow and so on and
so on
in a sense whatever we think of as new
it's so tricky like it depends on what
what the heck are we defining as novel
as creative and I'm sure if we could
look into our brain with a certain
amount of resolution and we had the
correct model if it even could be
modeled computationally but regardless
maybe there's some non-computational
model if it can even be modeled
quote-unquote model the point is that I
imagine it's conceivable to me that what
we think of as outputting something
creative is something that is
algorithmic like I'm not set on this but
it's conceivable and if that's the case
then I don't see why a computer can't do
it now whether or not a computer can
feel and understand what it's doing like
that's a separate problem but the actual
output I don't see an in principle
reason why it can't be done and I'm
telling you this as a romantic like I
don't want this to be done but I see
more and more like aspects that we
thought computers could not do
it couldn't beat us a chest and then but
well I can't create art oh my gosh can
it create art and can't compose music oh
my gosh can it confuse different musical
styles so it keeps encroaching
encroaching into these areas that we
thought this were just exclusive to
humans well what's left for us is like
physical dexterity and that seems to be
it so far my question is are you
confident in the statement that there's
something special about human creativity
I would like that to be the cake I want
to be convinced of that
well first of all when you said uh
that something cannot be done you cannot
demonstrate that something cannot be
done you can only demonstrate that
something can be done by doing it right
so I I will not be able or I don't think
anybody would be able to demonstrate
that computers cannot do something
but I am a computer scientist I I've you
know I programmed a lot
I work with computers a lot and I know
that the computers are good at doing
repeatedly certain things
and repeating patterns that already
exist right
you you cannot have an algorithm to
create something that does not exist I
mean
there is novel that is Meaningful of
course you can create novel things you
can create chaos right
you can create a random generator then
this sequence of randomly generated
numbers is unique is it novel
no because it doesn't make sense
are you afraid of where AI may be or are
you more hopeful
I think it's a serious issue and we have
to think about it you know because
the danger I see is that people will
trust those programs too much
and they uh we build them and we are
responsible for telling them what we
want them to do
if we don't do this right they may do
surprising things that we never actually
anticipated
I think the key thing is that we want
these things to be transparent we want
to know if they tell us
a statement then we want to know why
they think the statement is true
we want them to provide a proof of
something that they state
obviously they are not at this level yet
right
for example
they can write basically history books
right let's
we don't know whether they are
hallucinating or is it actual facts
they're talking about
so there must be some way of them
providing evidence
of what they are saying is true
like put references when you make a
statement like exactly exactly yeah so
we I've been talking to students
recently
about
what is true right like if
how can we decide if if a sentence is
true or false me
and and the fact is that
you know some people say Everything's
Relative you know like some people think
this is true and the other people you
think this is true I what I what I want
to the students to do is to decide
first what is the speaker what's the
author of the utterance if they think
it's true or not and this is non-trivial
but if they can establish that the the
author of the utterance or sentence
believes it's true
then it is true with respect to that
person right so we can say this is a
true statement according to this person
and it it is then kind of clear
that this is some kind of evidence based
on somebody's belief
so I do believe we can tell whether a
statement is true or false modular
the author of the statement
except in the case of AI like in the
case of people we can because they have
intentions but AI is no
currently no is there a subfield in
computer science that's dedicated to
this problem how did the machine come
upon this decision can it explain the
reasons
yeah many people are working on that
because many people have realized that
this is what we need in order to be able
to use those tools
and what's that field called or subfield
well the field that I worked in is
called natural language processing
uh and that's sometimes considered to be
a synonym of computational linguistics
is there a name for when you're
specifically trying to
pry open that black box and then pull
out something that is understandable to
us
like how did it make the decision
the word that I've heard uses
interpretability right so you want to
have a program that not just does the
job but is also interpretable so it can
be we can interpret why it does the job
as it does so the current
non-interpretability of AI is that what
you see as its greatest threat or do you
see that like you've heard strong Ai and
you've heard of The Singularity and that
machines may turn on humans or that
other people may use like if you invert
certain parameters then a drug that was
that a machine developed to produce a
drug that was helpful can be turned to
produce a drug that's extremely potent
and deleterious do you see the
non-interpretability of machines as the
greatest issue that we have right now or
is somehow connected to all those other
issues
I don't know if it's the greatest issue
but it's an important issue another
important issue is the so-called bias
right the these language models are
trained on texts that have been written
by people that are biased right and they
become biased themselves obviously we
don't want that to be guided by such
kind of texts
there's a phrase that you wrote down
English orthography is not close to
Optimal correct can you explain firstly
what orthography is and then take us
through that phrase
yes so orthography is the way we write
language so English exists primarily as
the spoken thing
but we also write it down like as every
language and
the orthograph is the way we write down
the sounds and as you may know English
doesn't have a very good orthography
well it doesn't seem to be good because
it's very hard to learn and people that
learn English they make a lot of
spelling errors and even native speakers
find it difficult to write down words
that they speak
so a Noam Chomsky had that a kind of a
statement that English orthography is
near optimal right it's close to Optimal
even though it appears not to be
so we had the projects when we when we
kind of showed that
it actually is not optimal it's not
close to Optimal it could be much better
and so that's the essence of that paper
why did Chomsky think that it was
Chomsky had ever had very good reasons
for saying what what he said but uh you
know in science
our job is to question everything right
and that's what we did in that project
we we wanted to question that statement
which seems to be nowadays accepted as
Truth by everybody
and to show that to to provide evidence
for that we we wrote programs and we did
such simulations
and we published this to show that
it is not actually optimal it is it is
not close to Optima could be much better
um
Yeah so basically that that's the point
here
what was chomsky's reasons for
suggesting it was optimal because as you
pointed out it seems on the face that
it's clear it's not like the word tough
is with an F but it ends with GH it
seems clear that it's not so Chomsky
must have had some reasons and like you
mentioned he had good reasons what were
they and then what was his response to
if any to to your results
yes so Chomsky was when he wrote this in
the 60s he was going against the the
consensus right which was that English
orthography is is
bad okay
and he questioned that and he said no
it's actually near optimal
and it would take a lot of time to go
into those arguments which are which are
reasonable
however
every every there is more to it right
every everything can be interpreted in
different ways and
the the main assumption uh that is
not spoken is that our writing system in
English is based on a history of English
and other languages
for example a lot of English at some
point was very influenced by French
about a thousand years ago and and that
influenced the spelling of English
now even if we if we could change the
orthography of English
to something better if if there is
something better then that wouldn't be
practically possible because people are
just used to the way as it is written
right now
and besides English is spoken in many
different languages in countries and
those countries would never agree on on
a new system
so so in a sense uh Chomsky was right
about so-called morphological
consistency
that words that have the same morphemes
which are pronounced differently should
have the same representation for the
Murphy that representation shouldn't
change
but there is also something called
phonetic consistency and you gave
example of that
and that is just not good right there
are just too many
arbitrary solutions that reflect the
pronunciation that as it was 500 years
ago
for example they were tough as you said
was actually pronounced with a consonant
at the end 500 years ago
no not tough but there are things like
though for example which also ends with
GH there's morphological consistency
phonetic consistency and then there's
orthographical optimality can you place
numbers on those like you can say this
language is 90 optimal orthographically
and at 50
morphologically consistent can you
actually Place numbers on them
yeah so let me give it right so for
example finish is considered an
extremely good
orthography is completely consistent you
know in all uh kind of aspects
um
some languages are like
Croatian for example
is a the orthography was created under
the principle right as you speak so that
has this consistency that
you can just uh you could you don't you
never make spelling mistakes you just
write as you speak
sorry which language was based like that
that sounds interesting
that's uh the the server it used to be
server creation now these are separate
languages but it still applies to it
Croatia Knight now Spanish which many
people are familiar with this is another
type of language where you know always
know how to read something you may you
may still make spelling mistakes
but you will never pronounce a written
word in a wrong way
so that's another type of consistency
the English doesn't have either of those
right you can
you as a native speaker will probably
make mistakes unless you have a spell
checker even though you know perfectly
well how to pronounce a word
and me as a second language learner of
English I will encounter words that I
just don't know how to pronounce right
so it is definitely a problem in English
but other languages are even more
difficult like the Japanese
orthographic system is even more
difficult than English
I'm curious if English stands out as
best or worse in some Metric and if so
which for instance I heard that English
can convey a complex sentence second
best something like that and Mandarin is
first you can think of it as a simple
language as one that a child may just
come up with on their own and it goes
ooh and ah and the complexity of what
they can convey is small and so somehow
there's some way of measuring that I
don't know I don't know the the actual
terminology I just heard this and I
heard that English is actually pretty
great it's second in the world and
Chinese or sorry or Mandarin is best at
that but anyway the point is I just
heard this so what is English great ad
and not great at
yes so so English English and Chinese
have something in common which is that
they are analytic languages so
morphology in English is is very basic
compared to languages like Spanish or
polish
oh and in in uh in Chinese it's even
more simple basically there is no
morphology at all
so in that in that sense these
analytical languages uh reach some kind
of
maximum at some
within that particular condition
I I know that um
English is if you compare things written
in different languages
sometimes you see on products like 20
languages with the same message
the English text will probably be one of
the shortest ones
so I I think this is maybe something
you're referring to that
that it can actually
convey the same message with fewer
letters or fewer symbols
reminds me of this joke someone was
translating I think it's I think this
actually happened I think it was from
hideo Kojima who's a video game creator
and he was on stage she speaks Japanese
and he says he goes
It goes on for like 20 seconds 30
seconds and the translator comes he says
thank you
laughs
you're like that's not what he's like
just
if you don't if you're lazy or you've
forgotten that's fine but just there's
no way that's all of what he said yeah
yeah well I I actually lived in Japan
for a while so this is actually the
issue of pragmatics right
uh language human language is not just
exchanging messages it's there's a lot
of for example related to politeness
uh and in in in Japanese you spend a lot
of time just being polite in addition to
passing a message ah like sand sand at
the end of a person's name is that take
a note I Am lower than you or respect
yeah there is a lot more tools for
expressing this kind of relationships in
Japanese
uh to give a simpler example in in
Spanish for example you can refer to
somebody as two or you
or usted which is like sir
but in English it's that that doesn't
exist you just call you everyone
so that makes things simpler
do you know who Larry David is from
Seinfeld
uh yeah I've watched Seinfeld yeah Larry
David the Creator he said that when
Caesar was being assassinated by Brutus
that Brutus said something with the two
and then then Larry David said that was
too informal for an assassination you
should be saying instead
foreign
to end this you did your Master's thesis
on a theoretical evaluation on selected
backtracking algorithms so how has your
perspective on that subject since the
writing of that thesis changed how is it
developed
yeah so I I did this this is part of
what's called artificial intelligence
but it's a very formal thing like uh
constraint called constraint
satisfaction and what I liked about it
is that you can actually prove something
I mean
unlike in pure Linguistics you can never
prove anything you can just argue about
it and then some people will disagree
but I didn't stay in that area because I
wanted to work with language that I love
language
and then I found that in in language
it's very hard to prove anything because
there are always exceptions
but now after though all those years I'm
coming back to the point that I think
that I can actually use the language of
mathematics to describe human language
and I find this very exciting so I I
hope to be able to prove things
and then be actually
safe in saying that
I'm I'm saying the right thing I'm
saying the truth because it has been
proven
what's one of the more out there
theories of the Voynich manuscript as to
what it's about what it contains
information on that you don't believe in
but you find interesting maybe even
plausible
so there was this hilarious paper and
somebody
trying to show that the language of
vines is actually Lodge Bank
I don't know if you've heard about it
it's it's a it's an invented language
and and this paper showed to me that you
can actually uh
provide evidence for anything for any
language if it's a large band that was
invented in the 20th century somebody
wrote Vonage manuscript in the 15th
century in that language
then that means you can basically argue
for anything
and that again shows the value of if you
can actually prove something and in the
case of the orange manuscript the proof
would be actually in the pudding which
means
deciphering it into some kind of
text that made sense
do you think it will be deciphered in
the next five years
no I I hope it will be I hope it will
buy wooden Bet On It
you know the people said uh before in
the in the history people often said
something will never be done and it was
done
when I first heard about the Zodiac
Cipher
I thought no that's not ever never gonna
be deciphered because it's probably just
random night and then it turns out that
it was deciphered so
that's a lesson for us
meaning in the case of the zodiac you
thought that it was gibberish but he
didn't actually write anything it's not
something that was deciphered it's just
symbols
yeah I thought it was just the
intentional gibberish to confuse people
this is similar to the people that say
that Vines is a joke right it's uh uh
they they make the same assumption that
somebody just did it to confuse people
well thank you for spending about two
hours with me or an hour and a half on
what is potentially a joke but we
hopefully not
take care man it's good to speak with
you thank you it was it was fun talking
to you
bye
the podcast is now concluded thank you
for watching if you haven't subscribed
or clicked on that like button now would
be a great time to do so as each
subscribe and like helps YouTube push
this content to more people also I
recently found out that external links
count plenty toward the algorithm which
means that when you share on Twitter on
Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on toe full-time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you